la plus grande réalisation à mettre au
crédit de stephen harper et des
conservateurs c'est d'avoir réussi à
réunir
les la droite et les conservateurs au
sein d'une même formation politique est
d'être capable d'être un gouvernement
majoritaire à partir de 2011 c'est la
plus grande réalisation parce que ça
impliquait une réorganisation
institutionnelle du parti mais aussi une
reconstruction intellectuelle pour les
conservateurs
quant à son pire sapir réalisation mon
avis c'est le délaissement des relations
avec les provinces absence de dialogue
avec les provinces lorsqu'il y ait un
dialogue c'est toujours avec une ou deux
provinces mais jamais dangereux
provinciaux qui sont vues d'une manière
plus générale entre le premier ministre
et toutes les provinces et donc les
canaux de communication ne sont tout
simplement pas là est ce qui définit je
pense encore le canada aujourd'hui ça
reste encore le fait que le canada est
perçu dans l'imaginaire des canadiens
comme étant un canada de casques bleus
passif et qui s'interpose entre les
belligérants plutôt qu'un canada qui
prend acte ou qui prend part au conflit
les conservateurs ont essayé de changer
cette perception mais ça demeure encore
très prégnant dans l'imaginaire canadien